[Musica]
con questo suono vi invito a venire con
me in un viaggio nel
tempo Mettetevi comodi fate un respiro
profondo e chiudete gli
occhi Sì il mio invito è proprio che vi
mettiate in
gioco Chiudete tutti gli
occhi immagina imate che di fronte a voi
ci sia una
persona questa persona vi dice che avete
tre giorni di
vita tre
giorni
Oggi domani
dopodomani non è un modo di dire la
vostra vita finirà tre
giorni sentite riecheggiare queste
parole dentro di
voi e se questa persona vi
chiedesse cos'è il tempo per voi ora che
sapete che ne avete così poco a
disposizione la risposta potrebbe non
arrivarvi
immediatamente Per cui vi chiedo di
entrare dentro di voi e
chiedervi cos'è il tempo per
voi lì vicino c'è una ragazzina di 14
anni alla quale questa persona fa la
stessa
domanda cos'è il tempo per te a 14
anni la ragazzina in modo naturale e
immediato
risponde il tempo per me
un'opportunità un mezzo per realizzare i
miei sogni per fare tutte le esze
possibili per essere più felice
possibile A meno che a voi della vita
non importi A meno che voi abbiate
deciso di lasciarvi vivere la vostra
risposta non differirà molto da quella
della
ragazzina il tempo è opportunità è sogni
è
desideri il tempo è tutto tutto quello
che si può
fare
improvvisamente se sentissimo fatica o
sonno non ci daremo peso perché Cosa
sono sonno e fatica a fronte di 72 ore
le nostre ultime 72 ore di vita
probabilmente le vivremo come un limite
a vivere
L'esperienza e se avessimo
fame è probabile che la metteremo a
tacere con qualcosa al volo mettendo le
scarpe uscendo per andare a vivere nel
mondo perché stare seduti a tavola con
posti è una perdita di tempo e noi di
tempo ne abbiamo
poco
e non ci importerebbe
delle conseguenze perché quella regola
di cui siamo sempre stati portatori
diventerebbe la nostra prima grande
trasgressione e anche in questo viaggio
Il tempo scorre e di giorni che ci
rimangono sono solo
due 48 ore
minuti per cui tagliare l'erba sistemare
camera Chi ha tempo per fare tutto
questo non c'è più tempo
e se qualcuno ci invitasse a fare
un'esperienza magari fino a poco tempo
prima di questo non ci interessava la
faramo subito perché non siamo in un
videogioco non c'è un bonus
vita e abbiamo litigato con qualcuno lo
sappiamo che un abbraccio riduce le
distanze scioglierebbe il
conflitto probabilmente non esiteremo a
darlo non abbiamo più tempo e il tempo
passa e manca un solo giorno 24 ore 1440
minuti come lo vogliamo
trascorrere sicuramente con intensità
gustando e assaporando ogni istante
il tempo sta per
concludere vi ho portato con me nel
mondo degli adolescenti per farvi
sentire sulla vostra pelle come vivono
il
tempo la morte per loro non è un
pensiero non li sfiora
minimamente Perché loro hanno fame di
vita la stessa fame di vita che noi
sentiamo solo se pensiamo che stiamo per
morire e in questa fame di vita in
questo tempo da vivere appieno cose come
tornare nell'istante concordato con i
genitori studiare tutto il
pomeriggio oppure prepararsi per una
visita o masticare con calma Non solo
queste cose per l'adolescente passano in
secondo piano non le considera
minimamente perché restare fino
all'ultimo istante ad un ritrovo con i
compagni e nutrirsi di quelle relazioni
che sono così importanti che sono così
nutritive oppure ascoltare e riascoltare
infinite volte quella canzone che fa
loro ricordare la persona di cui sono
innamorati per cui G batte il
cuore oppure sistemarsi e risistemo il
trucco infinite volte per un'uscita
che è quella
decisiva tutto questo per l' non un ha
prezzo
noi sentiamo che tutto questo non ha
prezzo solo se ci viene tolto solo se
pensiamo che stiamo per
morire Siamo arrivati a destinazione per
cui potete aprire gli
occhi vi ho portato con me in questo
viaggio simbolico non per farvi stare su
una fine ma per farvi stare su un nuovo
inizio su un modo nuovo di guardare AG
adolescenti sentendo la preziosità del
tempo che stanno
vivendo vi svelo un particolare che non
possiamo non considerare l'area deputata
a coordinare e a regolare il
comportamento sociale che determina il
controllo degli impulsi e la gestione
delle emozioni che è la corteccia
prefrontale matura intorno ai 20 anni
per cui quando giudichiamo gli
adolescenti incapaci di portare a
termine i compiti assegnati oppure
riteniamo esagerate le loro reazioni
emotive di pianto o di scoppio o di
rabbia
improvvise pensiamo che queste l'area
deputata a questo si sta ancora
sviluppando e quindi nel frattempo siamo
noi adulti che fungiamo da corteccia
prefrontale per loro con il nostro ruolo
di
Faro
guida contenitore e regolatore
emotivo guardiamo con tenerezza gli
adolescenti ponendoci accanto favorendo
la loro autonomia e
sostenendoli il mio augurio per gli
adolescenti è che possono incontrare
nella loro vita adulti soddisfatti della
loro
vita sostenitori dei veri
tifosi Facile a
dirsi ma come possiamo fare Vi svelo un
segreto vi do un suggerimento o
meglio poniamoci queste tre importanti
domande nella fine della mia giornata
Quando torno a casa mi sento
tendenzialmente soddisfatto della
giornata e
poi le scelte che io faccio nella mia
vita sono in linea con la persona che
sono con i miei valori e infine le
persone di cui mi circondo sono delle
persone che sento che mi amano che mi
rispettano e mi
rispecchiano se risponderete di sì
Sarete dei veri
sostenitori l'educazione degli
adolescenti Non si insegna si
dimostra
Grazie
n